édifice chouchou des millions de
touristes qui visitent la capitale
chaque année point de rendez vous des
politiciens fédéraux depuis plus d'un
siècle le château laurier se dresse au
pied de la colline parlementaire comme
far architectural à ottawa mais son
apparence pourrait bientôt changer
les sept otages seraient au dessus de la
corniche de cuivre que l'on voit le
conseiller municipal de rideau-vanier
veut à tout prix empêcher la
construction d'une annexe qu'il juge
trop imposante la firme l'arrco
investments propriétaire de l'hôtel veut
y ajouter 147 chambres une annexe de
sept étages construite dans un style
contemporain avec une architecture bien
différente de l'édifice existant
certains les comparant à un ut de
climatiser sortait à une grille de
barbecue on voit que pour un batna qui
est aussi raffinée qui est aussi où les
matériaux sont riches au niveau de
l'architecturé que l'on est vraiment il
ya vraiment
un risque au niveau de la contacter
compatibilité il aura fallu cinq
tentatives au propriétaire du bâtiment
pour obtenir un permis pour faire ces
changements
mathieu fleury propose une motion pour
le révoquer
le vote se tiendra demain au conseil
municipal de la ville d'ottawa et il
s'annonce serré moi ce que je dis à mes
collègues c'est important prendre la
bonne décision et c6 est protégé le
paysage de notre capitalisme à mattawa
le château laurier est située juste à
côté du canal rideau
classé patrimoine mondial de l'unesco
construit au début du siècle surnommée
la troisième chambre du parlement
il a été témoin au fil des décennies des
événements marquants du canada son
histoire est imbriqué dans celle du pays
la ville d'ottawa a recueilli plus de
2000 à vie lors de consultations
publiques sur la construction d' annexes
la grande majorité des participants ont
rejeté les plans proposés dans les rues
d'ottawa
les amis sont également presque unanime
on évalue que sa fille était apte à
recevoir une telle hystérie pour moi la
combinations de vieux et nouveaux je
trouve ça pas très joli il faudrait
rajouter peut-être ont-ils plus
adéquat de chant château mail art qu
investment n'entend pas lâcher le
morceau et menacent de poursuivre la
ville dans une lettre expédiée au maire
d'ottawa et aux conseillers municipaux
les porte parole de la firme soutiennent
que la révocation de permis n'est
probablement pas légal et résultera
certainement en aux litiges coûteux aux
frais des contribuables dont le résultat
probable sera le maintien par les
tribunaux de l'approbation du projet là
recours à tels que le château n'est pas
un édifice public mais un bâtiment privé
l'entreprise a décliné notre demande
d'entrevue le problème vient vraiment de
le manque d'une process public pour un
buffet offert un projet comme ça le
débat déborde de la capitale fédérale à
montréal l'architecte de renom phyllis
lambert s'est joint au groupe les amis
du château laurier
la fondatrice du centre canadien
d'architecturé invite le promoteur à
retourner à la planche à dessin
ce à l'encontre de tous leurs pouvoirs
je traite europe pour puisse avoir
et puis s'avère de prison vaut le
gouvernement fédéral ne s'est pas mêlé
du dossier pour l'instant affirmant
qu'il s'agit d'un enjeu municipal mais
la pression populaire pourrait le forcer
à se mouiller ici famille olivier radio
canada ottawa